I'd rather move in the wrong
direction than not move at all because I
believe that when we step out even if
it's the complete wrong direction God
will turn us to the right direction
because when we do the possible we see
God do the
impossible this is the second time we've
had Samuel speak at one of our
conferences he was excellent last time
and he was excellent this time bring him
along because he's got great knowledge
um and he present in a really humorous
way our guys were really engaged we come
in with nothing and we're going to come
out with nothing our short life here on
Earth is just a GPH I was really
impressed with the amazing value and
content Samuel G across the B so really
great speaker listen to what he's got to
say these chains of Injustice to set the
captives free to cloth the naked to feed
the hungry to preach the good news of
Jesus and that is what I wanted to do
but I needed to use my entrepreneurial
mind set to do it fantastic five key
point to to success Financial Freedom
you need to get his film bless you see
you soon this is probably the best
presentation I've ever heard if you've
got a church event or Christian
Conference and you want your people to
be empowered inspired and equipped and
be able to step into their coing then
speak to me I'd love to
[Music]
help